support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
microsoft com / people ready
we should be deaf or blind to history
and I think a lot of the gesture ation
of those thoughts are in fact
historically related but in every
previous downturn it has in fact been
you know new or smaller or growth
company businesses that have pulled the
economy out of the recession doesn't
mean that large companies are important
and clearly are but you know the engine
of job creation around the upturn here
will undoubtedly be located much more in
the smaller businesses and the new
businesses than initially in the larger
companies there'll be a rebound
hopefully I respect in the larger
companies but you know the notion of
creative destruction which is the shunt
Peter from like it's the last century is
as true today as it was then and I you
know clay Christensen over at Harvard
Business School augmented that thought
process with the innovators dilemma
innovative solution series of books
which are great reads and speak to all
this which is you've got to keep pushing
the ball forward and we've got to keep
making things better and invariably a
lot more not all but a lot more of the
innovation comes out of newer smaller
more nimble companies
well I is a lot of lessons and you know
to the to the extent that I'm sort of
hedging my bets here and suggesting that
they'll certainly be a percentage of the
recovery that will be large company
driven it's around the fact that you
can't get to be a large company these
days without being pretty darn smart and
part of that intelligence is
understanding how to learn right this
idea of a learning organization and to
the I guess that again the generation of
your question is that a lot of those
companies have in fact spent a lot of
time figuring out how they can be you
know less big and more nimble and you
know folks like Cisco and others are I
think key examples of that who are
trying to recreate and regenerate
themselves time and time again support
for big thing comes from Microsoft
delivering people ready enterprise
solutions designed to help companies do
more with less details at microsoft.com
/ people ready